[Música]
en Turquía y Siria están ya finalizando
las tareas set de rescate para dar paso
a la remoción de escombros y más
prioridad a la atención de
sobrevivientes el terremoto que es uno
de los más mortíferos de la última
década acapara la atención mundial y el
trabajo periodístico Es indispensable en
la memoria de sus múltiples tragedias
nos preguntamos Entonces si nuestro
trabajo desde los medios está a la
altura de los derechos humanos y Qué
podemos hacer para una cobertura que no
revictimice para conversar sobre el tema
nos acompaña Abelardo Gómez él es
presidente de la asociación o consejo de
redacción y cofundadora de cola de rata
medio donativo digital Muchísimas
gracias a usted por estar con nosotros y
bueno consejo de reacción se encarga
precisamente de aclarar estos temas se
tiende a hablar desde la lástima Y desde
la amarillismo Cómo cambiar el tono pero
manteniendo el respeto que esta
situación requiere
Buenos días Ángela y buenos días a todos
quienes nos están viendo en este momento
pues a ver Creo yo que hay varias
situaciones la primera es que
en una tragedia es una situación de
crisis que por lo regular los
periodistas cubrimos de manera
intempestiva nadie planea una tragedia y
mucho menos nadie planea descubrimiento
de una tragedia por lo tanto sobre la
marcha muchas veces debemos tomar
decisiones que aunque se hagan manuales
perfeccionando como comportarse es
imposible prever situaciones específicas
que se den en el momento de cubrimiento
En ese sentido Yo creo que es necesario
y primordial que el periodista tenga
algo que es muy difícil de conseguir
espacios como estos en los cuales hay
decenas o centenares de heridos muertos
caos y es tener serenidad y esa
serenidad no solamente para
contenerse a sí mismo también serenidad
para abordar a las personas y pensar el
contexto en el que está y no caer en
esas preguntas tan estúpidas y tan
terribles que repetidamente vemos en
algunos medios
Bueno pues esto ayuda un poco a
reivindicar que tampoco lo tenemos fácil
del lado de entregar la información sin
embargo una situación que se produce una
y otra vez cuando se están reportando
tragedias es la revictimización qué es
esto Cómo evitarlo
en esos espacios de
victimización
desgraciadamente repetitiva de cómo está
o cómo se siente y yo creo que esa
pregunta en un contexto de una tragedia
esa pregunta que es absolutamente
innecesaria son las una pregunta que no
no conduce a nada Yo creo que los
entrevistados en un momento de tragedia
deben ser conversados previamente para
poder tener con ellos una cercanía para
poder tener con ellos en algo que es una
palabra que muy es un lugar común muy
repetitiva Pero creo que es necesario es
el impacto es griego O sea la empatía el
haber sentirme como el otro con esa otra
persona y poder tratar de tener la
información que es necesaria que la
gente desea conocer pero que también
respete
el dolor de los demás creo que en estos
asuntos tiene un libro que muy clásico
que es ante el dolor de los demás y muy
bueno que los reporteros y algún día Les
llegan a este libro que dan muchas
claves sobre cómo abordar a estas
personas o en pro en hacer estas
preguntas innecesarias
es entablar la fuerza personal un
diálogo con esto no podemos ser amigos
en nuestras Fuentes yo lo sé pero sí
podemos ser personas empáticas entender
su contexto
tener las consideraciones especiales de
de cada individuo que entrevistamos y
siempre con la mayor sensibilidad y
mayor tacto hacer las preguntas
pertinentes para obtener información que
sea global y no caer en en hechos de
amarillismo que son muy vendedores entre
comillas En algunos medios pero que
definitivamente son un desastre para un
buen ejercicio periodístico ahora estas
preguntas que yo lo hago que yo le hago
me sirven para mí como periodista pero
también le sirven a la audiencia para
elegir Qué medios de comunicación ver o
por qué medios informarse y es que más
allá de las cifras que son importantes
cómo nos mantenemos en lo humano que
sucede en la zona de desastre usted
hablaba hace un momento de la empatía
Pero esto es difícil especialmente en un
caso como el que vemos ahora de Turquía
y de Siria porque están muy físicamente
alejados de nosotros
Pues yo creo que hay algo que nos une el
Humano
el poeta metafísico inglés donde decía
muy bien cuando muere un ser humano en
cualquier lugar del planeta ha muerto
parte de nosotros es el sentimiento de
tener afinidad por la humanidad sentir
que los humanos Somos todos sin importar
etnias sin importar religión partido
político y mucho menos distancia
geográfica yo creo que aquí usted pone
sobre el capital muy interesante que se
traslada por parte del público
consumidor de medios es elegir bien los
medios
las imágenes de manera prudente aquel
que no acude a los dantesco como una
manera de vender aquel que no acude a la
miseria humana como una manera de
entender el porno periodismo yo creo que
tener en cuenta estos valores por parte
del consumidor de medios es bien
importante y del periodista hay algo que
de pronto no se habla y me gustaría de
pronto comentar si es posible es también
como blindarse periodista porque los
periodistas también sufrimos en las
tragedias Y eso lo vi y yo lo viví en
carne viva en durante un terremoto muy
grave que hubo por esta zona del eje
Cafetero en el año 1999 nos llevó más de
mil muertos en esta zona en este
terremoto y lo que yo me di cuenta fue
que los periodistas en ese momento que
no teníamos suficientes armas para
blindarnos emocionalmente después del
terremoto se dio una desbandada en la
sala de redacción incluso muchos de los
periodistas salieron del país después de
eso porque sentían que el periodismo no
les ofrecía Horizontes en ese momento
Y eso también es una tarea en la que
tenemos que trabajar Los profesionales
de la comunicación Ahora hay un tema
extremadamente sensible y es la
cobertura de los niños hemos visto
imágenes incontables en los últimos ocho
días después del terremoto podemos
debemos mostrarlos Cómo hablamos de los
menores de edad
yo creo que las realidades
lo que se objeta o lo que se cuestiona
es como Mostrar esa realidad los niños
son parte de seguridad pero los niños en
particular merecen una protección
adicional un tacto extra por parte
periodista Así que un guante de arminio
que proteja mucho más a ese niño ante
situaciones tan terribles como las que
ocurren las tragedias yo creo que los
niños sirven con interés Y de pronto
varios medios quisiera equivocarme en
ello los utilizan con una manera
instrumental de conmover conmueven con
los niños y la idea no es como ver con
los niños sino la idea periodísticamente
hablando es Mostrar la situación de los
niños en un contexto difícil como ese y
un niño esté protegiendo a su hermano
debajo de unos escombros es parte de El
instinto natural de todos nosotros pero
hacer de eso una especie de indicación
del niño y de indicación de la tragedia
misma se convierte
se puede convertir en un despropósito y
se pierde la esencia inicial de mostrar
como entre los niños nace esa
solidaridad y también como entre niños
que son hermanos nace de esa necesidad
de protección del mayor hacia el menor
pero acá yo creo que nos ha faltado
tanto para manejar la presión de los
niños y no solamente en esta tragedia
sino en otras situaciones en las cuales
ellos estén involucrados merecería un
capítulo aparte y pues yo creo que tener
la prudencia tener entonces Esa palabra
que a veces en estas situaciones de
crisis como que se nos va por la borda
los periodistas y dejamos de tener tacto
porque nos llena la emoción o nos
conmovemos que es natural pero es una
conmoción que en nosotros Aunque suene
absurdo debe ser contenida así sea es
una contradicción en apariencia Bueno no
es que contamos sino cómo lo contamos
Abelardo Gómez presidente de la
asociación consejo de re y cofundador de
la cola de rata un medio nativo digital
gracias a usted Gracias a todos ustedes
muy amables